fareste interpretare questo quadro
tratto solamente a un algoritmo software
rispondere a questa domanda vi chiedo di
chiudere gli occhi ed immaginare di
essere nella vostra città
immaginate il traffico assordante
durante l'ora di punta
immaginate portoni che si aprono e si
chiudono camion che scaricano e caricano
merci immaginate anche il suono di
clacson di roberta che ha due gemelli ed
è stata bloccata da una macchina in
seconda fila
immaginate un martello pneumatico
l'amore in corso bimbi che corrono e
immaginate anche lontano il suono di una
tartaruga delle zampe di una tartaruga
che cammina lentamente inesorabilmente
seguendo il suo percorso
aprite pure gli occhi se li avete chiusi
e se avete immaginato il frastuono
cittadino così avrete anche sicuramente
immaginato la tartaruga è insignificante
il rumore dei passi della tartaruga
insignificante rispetto al frastuono
cittadino ma se la tartaruga ha impresso
nel suo carapace nel suo guscio la mappa
dell'universo dell'universo in cui
viviamo e dell'universo in cui siamo
nati allora quella tartaruga diventa la
cosa più importante che c'è la realtà è
un po differente immaginate di
sostituire le vostre orecchie con delle
parabole satellitari quelle per vedere
la televisione
e immaginate che è tutto il rumore
cittadino sia il rumore dello smog
elettromagnetico telefoni cellulari
forni a microonde televisioni wireless
digitale terrestre qualsiasi cosa che
mette un campo elettromagnetico ed è
incredibile
e non ce ne rendiamo conto che oltre a
questo rumore siamo investiti da una
radiazione elettromagnetica che ha avuto
origine a il tempo del big bang 14
miliardi di anni fa
mi piace pensare ma è così che se uscite
dal teatro
venite proprio investiti da questa
radiazione che si chiama radiazione
fossile o radiazione di fondo a
microonde che ha avuto origine 380.000
anni dopo il big bang e che è
praticamente costante la sua intensità
non varia
in realtà non è proprio così perché se
io la guardo da una direzione piuttosto
che un'altra
ci sono delle lievi differenze di
intensità e queste lievi differenze sono
talmente piccoli da essere una parte su
100.000
anzi dirò di più in polarizzazione
questa radiazione
supponendo di osservarla tipo con gli
occhiali polaroid di questa radiazione a
delle piccole differenze di una parte su
un milione e come misurare queste
differenze e come misurare le onde del
mare da una profonda dalla profondità
del dal fondo dell'oceano ma una
profondità di 100 km 10 volte di più
dalle fosse delle marianne
questa radiazione è stata misurata e
mappata e la vedete qui quelle lisse che
vedete non è nient'altro che la nostra
sfera celeste in cui siamo immersi e
quei punti ogni punto di quella mappa è
una direzione differente in cui
osserviamo e quelle differenze di
intensità sono quei colori diversi che
noi vediamo
e se la ingrandiamo questa mappa
scoprite una cosa che già conoscete la
differenza di un punto a un altro il
colore la grandezza di questi punti la
direzione di queste linea che vedete ci
dicono come è fatto l'universo che
l'universo era appunto vecchio 14
miliardi di anni fa anzi 13,700 99
miliardi di anni fa
e notate le tre cifre decimali come il
prezzo della benzina ci dice tante cose
ci dice che si sono accese alle prime
stelle dopo 700 milioni di anni ci dice
anche che l'universo ha subito una
incredibile un'incredibile periodo di
espansione all'inizio e si espande
ancora adesso ed è in accelerazione
questa espressione ci dice anche quella
mappa che gran parte dell'universo
noi non lo conosciamo perché riusciamo
solo a vedere il 5 per cento e sappiamo
che il 5 per cento dell'universo è
composto da materia ordinaria come il
nostro come il nostro corpo i nostri
atomi che il 26 per cento è composto da
materia oscura e non sappiamo cos'è e
addirittura il 69 per cento
dell'universo è composto da energia
oscura è come se avessimo un vasetto di
marmellata e con un cucchiaino
riuscissimo solo a mangiare il 5 per
cento
sapendo ben sapendo che tutto il resto
il 95 per cento del contenuto del
vasetto e la parte più buona più gustosa
ma che ancora non riusciamo a mangiare
quello che vi ho raccontato fino adesso
va sotto il nome di modello standard
dell'universo noi sappiamo che c'è stato
il big bang che ha avuto origine questa
radiazione fossile che si è espansa e
l'universo si è raffreddato fino ai
giorni nostri si sono formati alle
stelle le galassie finora fino al
momento in cui lo osserviamo e io ho
avuto la fortuna di lavorare per 15 anni
al satellite che ha fatto quella
fotografia dell'universo satellite si
chiama planck ed è stato lanciato
dall'agenzia spaziale europea il 14
maggio del 2009
ed è stato posizionato in un orbita
intorno al sole a un milione e mezzo di
chilometri dalla nostra terra ben al di
là dell'orbita lunare è affatto circa 2
milioni di giri su se stesso per mappare
in quattro anni l'intera volta celeste
all'interno del satellite ci sono stati
due strumenti un'italiana e una francese
e questi strumenti hanno osservato
l'universo a diverse frequenze diversi
colori e questo modo di osservare
diversi colori ci ha permesso di
separare il segnale del big bang da
tutto il resto dal segnale dalla
galassia il segnale dei passi della
tartaruga rumore dei passi della
tartaruga dal frastuono cittadino e
vedete qui l'immagine della nostra
galassia come è stata ottenuta da
satellite planck che è stata scartata
per osservare il big bang
ma questi dati sono serviti per studiare
la nostra galassia in un dettaglio
incredibilmente sofisticato e come ha
detto una mia collega esperto di analisi
dati i dati di planck i dati del
satellite planck sono come il maiale non
si butta via niente
quando ho iniziato a lavorare per planck
da un lato avevamo l'azzardo di proporre
nuove cose c'era poco o niente
c'era un'idea un progetto di massima e
propone avevamo l'azzardo appunto per
proporre nuove idee e nuove tecniche di
costruzione e dall'altro la
consapevolezza estrema di fare le cose
con un rigore in modo da poter lanciare
un satellite dal 700 milioni di euro
nello spazio senza nessun fallimento
blanc è stato un satellite
tecnologicamente incredibile ha dato il
via alla costruzione di satelliti che si
stanno sviluppando adesso secondo una
architettura studiata qui ogni singolo
pezzo di planck speciale viene mostra
soltanto due
questo ad esempio sono lunghi tubi due
metri di lunghezza che portano il
segnale da una temperatura di circa meno
250 gradi a una temperatura di circa a
temperatura ambiente e con vogliono il
segnale del di band e all'interno per
poi essere spedito a terra perché sopra
ci sono tre ci sono stati tre
frigoriferi talmente incredibili che
hanno permesso addirittura di
raffreddare alcune parti del satellite
fino alla temperatura di meno 270 gradi
centigradi anzi meno 273 gradi
centigradi
è un altro pezzo di planck che qui
vedete che qui era incastra questo come
luca ha misurato il laboratorio alle
caratteristiche termiche dell'intero
universo qui dentro in questo pezzo
c'è addirittura un intero universo che
ci è servito per fare per usarlo come
riferimento per le nostre osservazioni
io ho imparato tante cose lavorabilità
ho imparato anche che nella scienza dove
tutto è codificato e dove la tecnologia
è portata all'estremo il contributo
umano fatto di scommesse di idee di
esperienza è fondamentale e deve
rimanere fondamentale
ho imparato anche che le grandi scoperte
i grandi esperimenti nei grandi
scommesse dove il termine grande può
essere applicato a qualsiasi cosa che
facciamo sono possibili perché quando le
stiamo facendo abbiamo quella percezione
di fare un qualcosa di impossibile come
ad esempio francesco che ha deciso di
guardare uno per uno i dati di qualità
del satellite planck in volo perché non
era assolutamente convinto che anche i
software automatici potessero
controllarli bene e aveva ragione
o come maura che guardando col satellite
del pianeta giove ha scoperto come era
fatto il telescopio come c'era
modificato il telescopio a un milione e
mezzo di chilometri da noi o come
gianluca che con i refrigeratori di
planck è uno dei tre ha studiato ha
inventato il modo per rigenerarlo sempre
un milione e mezzo di chilometri in modo
che le osservazioni anziché durare 18
mesi sono durati quattro anni plancia
fornito un sacco di mappe ognuna le
abbiamo elaborate con algoritmi
sofisticati coi computer più potenti che
tra le varie mappe ognuna con un
differente taranto in differenti
parametri di analisi di quelle tante
mappe se ne sono state scelte se ne è
scelta una per rappresentare il nostro
universo il nostro modello di un livello
ma siamo certi di aver scelto la mappa
giusta e mi piace confrontare planck ha
una grossa macchina fotografica che ci
permette di fare fotografie a un livello
di dettaglio pazzesco incredibile poi
prendiamo queste fotografie le diamo in
pasto al gorini ad esempio di
riconoscimento dei volti ad esempio
algoritmi automatici che ce le
classificano in base al colore
predominante in base agli oggetti che ci
sono all'interno della foto o
addirittura si stanno sviluppando
algoritmi per decidere se una foto e
bella oppure no secondo i canoni
estetici standard della fotografia
questa cosa ci potrebbe mettere al
sicuro siamo ci sentiamo al sicuro di
fronte all'arrivo di queste tecnologie
ma siamo proprio veramente proprio
convinti di andare verso questa
direzione
oppure preferiamo ancora scegliere il
volto con un'espressione particolare e
ci piace ancora scegliere la fotografia
che è bella per noi
paragonando blanc alla nostra vita di
tutti i giorni
mi viene da chiedere se l'avanzare delle
tecnologie e l'utilizzo indiscriminato
delle tecnologie moderne si può
offuscare il privilegio umano
tipicamente umano di essere artisti
della nostra vita
insomma vi rifaccio la domanda fareste
analizzare questa mappa solamente a un
algoritmo software grazie
[Applauso]